becoming a sniper was my long cherished
dream
since childhood in fact
and even now i can recall in my new
details scenes from the pre-war film
sniper
it was about the feats of a super
accurate russian marksman in the first
world war in particular i vividly
remember the scenes from the film
dealing with the art of camouflage by
making a replica of a tree stump or a
dead horse and planting it in no man's
land a sniper could then climb into it
and hit the enemy accurately from there
i want through my narrative to open up
one more page in the history of the
great war for the fatherland
to describe how the snipers movement was
born and grew to mass proportions in
leningrad and played a huge role in the
positional trench warfare around the
besieged city
our academy commenced regular classes
from morning till night the cadets
strove to acquire as quickly as possible
all the tricks of the sniper's art which
lieutenant baturin willingly shared with
us
and so we set off to take the
examination it was a gloomy october
morning the trenches had long been
permeated with damp and the cold at
night had become more noticeable the
first significant amount of snow had
fallen the previous day straight onto
the dry frozen ground like a blanket
covering the crippled earth of leningrad
we all realized that our first wartime
winter would be very severe
[Music]
my partner was ivan dobrik a sturdy lad
of short stature with a broad
good-natured face with a perpetual sly
expression on it
he was an excellent marksman on the
smallest targets and a downright
outstanding serviceman
a column of smoke from the stoves of the
nazi dugouts was rising high into the
frosty sky and steam was pouring out of
the kitchens
hungry as we were it seemed to us that
the germans were being fed right round
the clock
through the telescopic sights of our
rifles we could see far into the depths
of their defenses and german soldiers
large as life both groups and
individuals occasionally wandering here
and there unfortunately beyond the range
of our bullets
we lay like that for a long time without
taking a single shot nestled up against
the snow-covered parapet and closely
pressed against each other lying in the
frost for several hours on end without
moving was not much fun and we were not
used to it the frost went right through
us we so wanted to get up and warm our
frozen feet and hands with some vigorous
movement but we knew this was impossible
we were in a lousy mood
it began to get dark
suddenly i noticed some moving targets
in my firing sector about 60 meters from
our observation point
ivan take a look i can see some nazis on
the right i cried out joyfully
completely forgetting that i was only
about 80 meters from the enemy front
line and could become a target myself
i'll take the last one then the first
one
dobre could spotted the nazis too
don't let them get away evgeny
making the usual adjustments to allow
for crosswind and the movement of the
target i set my sights on the head of
the last of the three nazis and holding
my breath smoothly press the trigger
the sound of a sniper's bullet is not
loud but its sting is lethal
i barely caught the sound of my short my
own heart was thumping much more loudly
it seemed to me i saw the last of the
germans sink down
the other two continued on their way
without noticing what had happened
cheered by my success i decided to shoot
the second nazi
the second conqueror also fell as if he
had tripped however he must have had
time to yell something because the first
soldier who had taken two of three
further steps forward stopped looked
around and went back up to his fallen
companion he stood over him
gesticulating with his hands and saying
something to the soldier lying immobile
he was possibly ticking him off for his
clumsiness or more likely suggesting
that he'd get back on his feet still
failing to guess what had actually
happened and certainly not expecting
what would happen a second later
i had more than enough time to reload
the rifle and take another shot
it made a sharp crack as if a woodpecker
had struck a dry fur tree with its
sturdy beak
and felled by my bullet
the third nazi collapsed dead on top of
the second
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
question adjusted for inflation how much
money did world war ii cost the united
states a 350 billion
b 4.1 trillion or c
60 trillion that's correct 4.1 trillion
or
341 billion at the time
and so my recommendation this week is
one of magellan's new documentaries
which they add every week that explores
one of the defining events of the
conflict pearl harbor inside the uss
arizona is an exploration of one of the
iconic remnants of that terrible day
using cutting-edge methods this
documentary explores the wreck and tells
its remarkable story
gripping stuff
and of course magellan have more than
three thousand other documentaries to
check out too
so click on the link in the description
for an exclusive month-long free trial
for voices of the past viewers
thanks
[Music]
a sniper has many enemies especially in
the summer apart from the main one the
enemy there are others from whom you can
never know what to expect they can be
bees wasps flies ants and even field
mice i remember once on a fine summer's
day ivan dobrik and i were lying in
ambush
we had to lie out in no man's land in
thick grass in a flat open area almost
right under the enemy's noses
we conducted observations of the german
front line and the approaches to it
having correctly calculated that in
thick grass in a flat field without a
single landmark it would be difficult
for the nazis to spot us we would have
laned there calmly till darkness fell
but for pure chance
my partner lying motionless in the
baking sun suddenly became an object of
interest to a tiny field mouse
how this curious daredevil got past his
tightly fastened belt into ivan's tunic
i still cannot understand while the
mouse was crawling around somewhere on
his back i even managed to put up with
it being afraid to move
but when it ventured lower down onto his
stomach and began to nip him dobrik's
patience snapped he suddenly bellowed
across the whole of no man's land and
began laughing hysterically
i was seriously afraid he had discarded
his rifle and was rolling around on the
grass and yelling with a heart-rending
voice what's up ivan are you out of your
mind there are germans right next to us
they'll spray us any minute now i said
in bewilderment the whole situation and
the expression on ivan's face as he
continued to roll around in the grass
put me in a foolishly merry mood
i too began to laugh
of course the nazis were not slow to
open fire with mortars
let's run for it ivan could barely utter
the words through tears of laughter and
grabbing his rifle he darted towards our
trenches pressing one hand to a wound
he'd only just suffered as he went
you've put on quite a show said the
observer escorting ivan and me
undercover have you turned into a couple
of halfwits or what
the constant bombing raids the
continuous artillery fire the pursuit of
enemy snipers the possibility that any
second you could become a target
yourself for an equally experienced
german marksman or perish from a stray
bullet or an enemy shell or mortar
fragment all made for constant tension
at night when we were off duty i used to
go and see my friend and fellow townsman
vlad dudin our company sergeant major
vlad and i had no trouble finding things
to talk about by the light of a homemade
oil lamp fueled by low-grade petrol or
fat we would recall the distant and
precious days of peacetime and of course
we recalled our hometown of tambov our
traumatically short youth our home
kith
and kin
one time we became so involved in our
conversation that dawn had already
broken beyond the dugout's closed door
we were reminded of it by our regimental
wit and master of sarcasm vlad kazerev
bursting into the dugout kazirav shouted
at us from the doorway his eyes sticking
out of his head
what are you sitting there for gambling
nonsense when the nazis have played such
a filthy trick on us what sort of trick
asked dude in irritation expecting as
usual from kazarev another prank or
practical joke the germans have put up a
plywood sign with nasty slogans against
us what are you gonna do we got to the
front line and indeed on top of a german
dugout stood a plywood sign on narrow
poles thrust into the snow
inscribed on it with charcoal and big
letters was greetings citizen come over
to our side in ungrammatical russian
[Music]
i settled comfortably into my deep dug
firing position my observation point was
well camouflaged on the side facing the
enemy and nothing was likely to be
detected from above our troops had long
been instructed in the art of camouflage
especially we snipers
it is no secret that the casual slack
and careless do not survive on the front
indecisively cautiously as if concerned
that his appearance would set machine
guns rattling and cause people to die
the sun glanced out it was now quite
light i had been studying the enemy
defenses for a long time the german
dugouts now and again someone would pass
by near them cautiously stooped over
they didn't need to worry it wasn't them
that interested me today
i took a look to the rear according to
what our scouts had told me their
headquarters ought to be somewhere there
earlier on any nazi headquarters was
easy to distinguish by the telephone
lines now the germans had become more
careful they'd begun to run the wires
along the ground and cover them with
snow
the main thing was the sentry walking
back and forth by their dugout
looks like that's the headquarters i
thought to myself and finally switched
all my attention to it
i estimated that it was roughly 700
meters away but estimating distance by
eye is one thing it needed to be checked
i set my sights at 700 meters and loaded
the rifle with a tracer cartridge
i chose a moment when the machine guns
were chattering on the edge of the front
line and covered by their noise took a
single shot
the bullet left a clear trace in the
door everything was precisely worked out
now it only remained to make a slight
adjustment to the site's drum
and await
the kill
a caught sight of three nazis leaving
the right heap of the dugout
one of them was naked to the waist while
the other two were minus overcoats just
in uniforms raising up his arms the
half-naked one began to walk around
bastard he's come out to do his
exercises i guessed
the other two began to wash their faces
with snow waiting for the moment when
the semi-naked man finally stopped and
began to do some squats i took my first
shot
the nazi squatted and collapsed onto the
snow and lay down as if he was going to
sunbathe glad to see the bright sun
one of the other men turned looked at
the lying man and apparently said
something to the other
he turned round
they both stood there and looked at the
man spread out on the snow then went up
and began to lift him up
then realizing what was up they started
looking round perplexed not realizing
where the bullet had come from they
didn't even look at our trenches
apparently thinking the distance was too
far
i didn't allow them to ponder for too
long and skewered both of them
and hardly had i got ready to fire again
when i saw a motorbike and sidecar
approaching the headquarters dugout the
motorcyclist rode up and stopped dead by
the door itself a tall german jumped
from the pillion in no time at all and
began to assist a fat nazi to get out of
the sidecar
while he was obligingly fiddling round
with this person of seemingly important
rank
i focused on the rider who had leaned
forward to rest on the handlebars
i fired
the tall man had turned to the
motorcyclist wishing i thought to
command him to leave but seeing that he
was apparently asleep over the
handlebars gave him a nudge
in vain however
after my shot the tall man also fell
backwards behind the motorcyclist
waving his arms enthusiasm is all very
well but the voice of reason was still
telling me enough for today you can't
stay in one place for so long they'll
get you i settled down into my deep
little foxhole there wasn't much room in
there and i was terribly thirsty i felt
the urge for a little sleep the extra
nervous tension had seemingly had an
effect so what i can relax a little bit
but i'd scarcely closed my eyes before a
shell whistled past and exploded
somewhere nearby leaping up immediately
i looked out of the trench and saw 300
meters away huge clumps of earth
settling back from on high several
minutes later i once again heard the
whistle of a flying shell it grew in
volume the explosion forced me to stoop
down lower in my foxhole this shell fell
about 100 meters away from me and closer
to the tram lines clearly the gunners
were aiming for me
but i never got to hear the next
explosion the next exploding shell
tossed up fresh tons of earth a huge
clump the size of a cauldron lid covered
me in my firing niche landing heavily on
my back
it's all over the thought race through
my mind i'll never dig my way out i've
got no more strength left and
something's weighing down heavily on me
in my ears in my mouth up my nose
again some blunt object landed on the
ground and something heavy struck me on
the head and rolled onto my shoulders
then there was total silence
darkness descended and i could think no
more
i came to an hour company command post
in a vast concrete pipe laid across the
tramline and right under it i was
sitting on a stool with my back leaning
against the pipe
some people were walking around me i
sort of recognized them and didn't
recognize them everything was in a fog
maybe i've gone deaf i thought
as they told me later i slept at the
command post for 18 hours uninterrupted
slept as i sat there
dear mum i'm not hiding anything
honestly i'm alive and well safe and
unharmed first i must tell you that vlad
duden and i are now on rest and
recreation in the rear it's a kind of
gratuity for us for example i recently
wiped out 11 nazis in a day and now i've
been rewarded yesterday a scout i know
dropped by in passing and said that
three days ago our troops had captured
an important nazi at interrogation this
man told us one of your snipers killed
11 gallant soldiers of our reich in two
hours
one was a general so now my tally
includes a general as well
so you see i am truthfully reporting my
activities at the front
now i'm waiting for your report on life
and work
evgeny
[Music]
december was a harsh month
the winter of 1941 to 1942 has remained
in everyone's memory it came early and
it was ferocious
the winter months became a difficult
test for both of us the defenders of
leningrad and for its residents
unsettled by their heavy losses the
german command was compelled to call in
troops urgently from other fronts and
direct their super sharp shooters
against leningrad
so aces like this expert masters of
their craft killers with seniority and
huge experience appeared in our area too
we quickly felt the presence of these
nazi snipers they would fire through the
slit of a pillbox and skillfully take
out our observers
i resolved to test myself against one of
the nazi ace snipers who had appeared in
our sector by tracking the path of the
nazi's shots back to their point of
origin i came to the conclusion that he
was sitting somewhere close to the tram
lines in the broad expanse in front of
our third platoon to the right of it and
closer to the gulf of finland
in no man's land
and so clad in a snow white camouflage
smock over my regular clothes i crawled
in that direction one dark and frosty
night
by first light i was already lying in no
man's land well camouflaged in the deep
snow
i was not concerned about concealment
but when i succeed in spotting the enemy
he would also be camouflaged against the
same snow one imagined just as well as i
was
and so i waited
however
it all turned out differently
suddenly i noticed against the pure
eye-testingly white snow a suspicious
little spot of something coloured
differently from snow had appeared and
thus while pondering and trying to
explain the reason for this spot i lost
sight of the most important thing the
thing i had been freezing so long for
but it all turned out to be very simple
beside this little spot on the surface a
big one suddenly appeared
in white camouflage
in a trace it crept up a couple of
meters to the left and disappeared as if
swallowed by the earth
from the unexpected nature of it all and
being chilled to the bone
i didn't even manage a shot
they literally carried me in their arms
to the dugout as my feet had refused to
move they were frozen and it appeared
frostbitten contact with hard surface
caused intolerable pain
but once again my friends came to the
rescue they took my footwear off in the
dugout and began to rub my feet with
snow and woolen gloves until i felt some
pin pricks the battalion medical
assistant was consulted
oh dear
no brains he said reproachfully you
should have smeared your feet with fat
before you went out wrap them in
newspaper and only then wound on your
foot wrappings
well i responded i'll do everything
scientifically tomorrow but today just
rub them make an effort to be a friend
in the morning i was awakened by the
company century
it's time up you get what already what a
pleasant dream you've interrupted i was
dreaming of my mother we were buying rye
flat cakes hot and fragrant
did you get to try one asked the century
he didn't give me a chance i answered
closing my eyes again enough betty bye
nicolaev you'll miss your nazi
that i was facing an experienced foe
there could be no doubt just as it could
not be doubted that he was already in
situ
he's outwitted me the bastard got there
earlier i thought when first light had
already dawned
tears began to form in my eyes from the
continuous observation of a single point
through telescopic sights it was the
wind blowing straight into my face and
the frost
i kept brushing away the tears while
trying not to make any obvious movements
the fingers of my right hand which were
constantly ready for action
had frozen and i began to worry as to
whether i would be able to hit the
target when necessary
i realized that in duels like this there
were no wounded
a sniper only ever makes a single
mistake
i had not taken a shot in over a week
and he had noticed that and was being
careful
i didn't have time to complete my
thought when suddenly something seemed
to prod me in the very heart and with
good reason the head of the nazi had
appeared from out of a trench above the
snowy covering all at once i felt hot
now just like yesterday he would drag
his large body out of the trench onto
the surface swiftly cover the three
meters distance and be off
no you must be joking you rat it won't
work this time and i firmly grasped the
rifle in my hands
the nazi's face firmly held in the
sights of my rifle was distinctly
visible through the eyepiece
he did not even glance in my direction i
had to bring him down and show everyone
that he was lying fallen on our land and
i was almost certain that any second now
he would leap out he was bound to repeat
his maneuver from yesterday only now i
knew about it and was expecting it
unsettled by the silence around and
hurried along by the intensifying frost
and gathering darkness with one short
jump the nazi landed up on the surface
of the ground stooping low he managed to
take his first
and last step
[Music]
the shot long awaited on our sector
resounded
like the crack of a whip echoing in the
frosty air it brought the nazi down onto
the snow his rifle now a danger no
longer to our troops slipped out of his
hands and fell at the feet of its dead
owner
at the end of 1942 i was transferred to
counter-intelligence and my sniper's
score was cut off at the total of 324
having liberated leningrad from the
enemy siege our division along with
other units of the leningrad front
pressed forward drove the nazis back and
reached their actual den
travelling the entire route with me was
my sniper's rifle the butt of which
still bears the three large two
medium-sized and four small stars traced
on it
during the war years
[Music]
you